I didn't give up to the corrupt Republic
I didn't give up to the Empire
and I won't give up to you I like this
they did the Law and Order SVU thing
yeah they had a big actor for this
episode
like it's him obviously it's it's Whoopi
Goldberg
I'm by the Jedi en Fortress oh no wait
he was just about to say it against
Skywalker we almost got it
oh we were so close that was awesome
welcome back to new rock stars the
Mandalorian chapter 22 was the lesson
for many and what it feels like to watch
Clone Wars sometimes your heroes are
just gonna end up in some whack-ass side
quest with drunk droids Jack Black and
lizzo Doc Brown screaming about Count
Dooku and Star-Crossed Seafood
let's discuss the bantha in the room
this is the break room presents
Wikileaks our weekly Mandalorian after
show I'm Eric Voss my Easter egg
breakdown is coming tomorrow but right
now I'm here discussing this interesting
episode with Tommy bechtold and Hector
Navarro Hello friends oh Eric it's bad
o'clock it's thick 30. I've been
gone so long but I'm still flirty
this episode had the juice and it had
The Delectable Mr JB so I just just
enjoyed every single morsel of this
Insanity I Hector I have to ask you're
wearing this great directory
is this what you expected the Bryce
Dallas Howard episode of the Season
would be absolutely do you know why
because Bryce Dallas Howard voiced
yaddle and yada was killed by Dooku so
Bryce Dallas Howard knows everything
about Count Dooku and was champing at
the bit to bring back Duku into the
Mandalorian so yes this is no of course
this isn't what I expected I expected
thrawn to show up but I'm happy that
Star Wars continues to try and be weird
because that's the best thing that Star
Wars can do don't take itself too too
seriously but uh we'll get to thrawn
we'll get there we'll get to thrawn for
now let's just enjoy lizzo and Jack
Black yeah Tommy take us through what
happened this episode thrawn makes me
yawn Liza
got the Rizzo all right so what the
are you gonna say something else
so what the fat happened in this episode
boys let's talk about it the episode
opens with a core and Freight ship
that's been hunted down by ex-wolves and
the rest of the Mando mercenaries that
split from Boca tan prior to this
season's events so from there we see
dinjarin grogu and bokotan have
immediately left Navarro they're like
we're out we're gone uh and they tracked
down uh Bo's old friends in the
independent Outer Rim world of plasir
15. yeah they all kept saying like I've
never heard of this planet what is this
planet I've never heard of it like it's
just a reminder that the Star Wars
universe is pretty expansive I'm just it
didn't seem like a real it was
like a pretty evolved planet that seemed
you know they they got some interesting
croquet just say it Eric it's Epcot this
is Epcot in Orlando that's what it
looked like straight up Epcot complete
with the monorails we were watching Walt
Disney's utopian idea of a perfect
Society from the 1970s that's whether
someone getting a margarita on one block
one block over they're eating a nice
sushi lunch that's right they're
definitely staying on property which you
know means they paid for it uh so they
they land they're greeted by these
Droids that kind of look like C-3PO and
rgd2 but then we see that they're just
old uh re refurbished reprogrammed
Imperial droids they're not the droids
we're looking for guys well I mean
unless that's your sort of thing evil
robots this doesn't bode well yeah an
ra7 who greets you yeah and anytime you
see a black Astromech droid I just have
a ton of questions yes what do you
really think of R2D2 is he a little
stinker and uh that guy's a little make
a case for yourself that Chopper is
actually the most evil Droid because he
is Chopper is a piece of well we're
all we're all dreading the day Chopper
appears uh again in live action to
torment Eric and honest dreams but first
the stuff that the dreams are made of we
get to meet Jack Black and lizzo as the
amazingly Star Wars name Captain
Bombardier and The Duchess Bombardier I
believe that's how Jack Black I'm saying
Bombardier because that's what it is but
you're right yes listen han han it it's
it's a Star Wars tradition we're gonna
have different pronunciations Han's best
friend calls him hand so I don't know
what to do uh yes
Jack Black doing some accent work from a
place that doesn't exist but I love well
it does exist it's Place R15 or whatever
uh all right so this is the Crux of this
episode boys old Imperial droids are
acting up we're seeing Droid violence on
the streets it's basically I Robot right
isn't this the plot of I Robot down to
like aggravating one Droid until he
fights back against you I'm surprised we
didn't have an Alan tudik Cameo playing
a version of k2so being like I did not
murder him yes you're right I did not
hit her I did not
so so it's uh it's up to Benson and
Stabler I mean Dan and Bo to figure out
what's going on and by the way I mean if
this episode wasn't heavily influenced
by law and order I don't know what to
tell you they literally go to a shipping
dock to talk to someone there's some
droids are just like yeah I've only met
the guy
sure I know him but he always kept to
himself uh they question Christopher
Lloyd whose name is literally Captain
Hellgate and by the way like Luke
Skywalker is the protagonist of this
entire thing yes so I'm not yes I'm not
proposing that these names are not
always silly this episode was just chock
full of them and I love it I eat it up
Yum Yum Yum Captain Hellgate he handles
surveillance across the city he shows
them some footage of a handful of droid
attacks and kind of pushes them along on
a theory for the situation which is
always suspicious when the person you're
talking to is like well you know here's
what I think it is well do you think his
plan in that moment was to like he knew
that they would aggravate one of those
uh battle droids and that they would
like kill them is that what he was
hoping or convince them that this isn't
worth their time right like he needs
them he needs those two out of the
picture because everything else is
working fine uh so then they go visit
the ugnots who are responsible for
smithing and working on the droids uh
they claim there aren't any
malfunctioning droids but after din just
you know basically threatens everyone
and din's move this time like he was
like a real hot head cop like there's a
lot of good cop bad cop in this episode
but in this room he was uh yeah he was
super polite he was like uh he recalled
his relationship with kuil and I really
this is my favorite part of this yeah to
be honest just liked his connection I
like that he said there's a way to speak
to them because Bo is so clearly like
why did you say I have spoken like yeah
she's so clearly thrown by that and he's
like there's a way to speak to them that
only I yeah yeah it was a wonderful uh
like Anchorman moment where he was like
I know Kata Zhao is my cousin you can
come and we'll help you you may go in
peace
uh he pulled a baxter from Anchorman is
what he did yes so they provide them uh
you know they give them some information
which leaves the duo to a loading doc as
I said din then provokes a Droid because
he hates them uh Bo's like let me ask a
question din's like I don't like that
answer I'm immediately choosing violence
uh but they get that uh spark pad which
takes them to the Droid bar the resistor
not a heavy-handed name at all and that
gets them a little closer to solving the
mystery they get to the resistor right
Bo tells Dan to this like let me handle
this and Dan's like sure no problem take
all the time you need psych you get 10
seconds to come up with something I'm
cutting people in half
so then they discover that the
malfunctioning droids were all served
the same batch of Nepenthe Nepenthe I'm
saying that right
yes you are I wanted to pente after this
but not the batch they got because it
was contaminated with something then
they go to the robot more
uh
artists are right that's so funny
in this uh this actor who they pulled to
play the mortician had a small role in
righteous gemstones as the person
walking is it the pharmacy or the
whatever at the at the store uh where
like they she brings back the lunch for
uh oh yeah
what what is a robot autopsy is that a
robot Topsy is that what we're dealing
with right here that's what we just
witnessed it great great
so so the two are two detective Heroes
continue their investigation before they
get any more information out the Droid
goes nuts and starts attacking them and
that's when we find out about the Nano
droids which feature a chain code that
points them back towards Hellgate yes if
a person is named tailgate they are
going to end up being evil guys I'm
sorry I don't know a lot of benevolent
hell gates in my life oh that's not true
I knew a Paul Hellgate once yeah he
murdered two guys
so it's revealed that Hellgate is the
one that commissioned the Droid attacks
in order to disrupt and attack the way
of life I'm pleasure remember they said
they were like why don't you just
decommission all the droids and then
they're like because they don't people
don't want to work they're like the
droids are it's like it's like uh Wally
yeah it really is
the people are just floating around in
chairs sipping Slurpees they don't want
to work anymore they cannot carry all
their hot box hat boxes they couldn't
possibly carry all their hat boxes too
they don't want to work they just want
to bang on the croquet mallets all day
uh I I do like that kind of like it's
like a convenience store it's like we
had to shudder for the weekend because
kids don't want to work it that's right
you want a job where you work they put
the piece of paper up we're so sorry but
we're not going to be able to be open
for lunch anymore because people want to
be paid a living wage uh anyway speaking
of radical political opinions Hellgate
reveals that he is a separatist and an
Ardent supporter of the late great Count
Dooku at some point grogu is knighted
Christopher Lloyd is exiled to a moon
and then we get to what is probably
the most important part of the episode
uh bo and didn't find the night owls and
uh Bowen ax wolves fight I I love this
guys I thought it was really cool they
used like they really showcased the
Mandalorian Weaponry that they have uh
when they're fighting foe wins din gives
Bo the darksaber and explains that when
he was out of commission din wielded or
Beau wielded the dark saber and saved
his life everybody's like yeah sure
we'll change the rules no problem that
sounds great that works for me what the
hell was this episode guys
yeah
yeah I mean uh I have so many questions
from that alone like we said we should
talk about that maybe a little bit later
uh I also have questions about those
droids like the nanodroids because the
nanodroids also get drunk and be
programmed oh separately sentient they
have their own bar inside the Droid they
have their own tiny little boxes
um before we get into talking about what
this episode was just a quick reminder
to support the new rockstars Network by
grabbing some merch over at
nerdright.shop we have some really cool
Mandalorian inspired designs I'm wearing
I think it's the first time I've worn
this Amanda hoodie that's a mythosar
hoodie it's really cozy star hoodie Eric
thank you so much for heralding the new
age of Mandalore by wearing that that's
gorgeous that's right I there was a
night owl and I shaved it off Eric is
the one to lead us Eric must ride the
mythosaur yes I have a long complicated
explanation of a story that I have no
evidence of that at some point someone
else fumbled the dark saber and yeah
that person's just gonna explain to you
in a rational conversation why it's
rightfully mine uh and it's all gonna be
based off of a conflict that we have
that happened off screen that we're just
gonna tell people about uh anyway we
have thoughts obviously and look you
know what this is Clone Wars this is how
Clone Wars feels and this is a divisive
episode but some people seem to be okay
with it because that was Clone Wars was
it was kind of a story of the week thing
but I think uh I'm gonna save some of my
thoughts for later in the in this
episode okay please calm down you're
you're heating up a little bit there
Eric yeah why don't you go ahead and
simmer Dan now okay we got it we got
some stuff to get into here we have some
stuff to get into this question of uh
separatism we're the steps right I have
all other political systems been
demonstrated to fail in Star Wars uh
we're seeing some Dooku Redemption here
and why is why are they so interested in
the character of Count Dooku suddenly in
Star Wars and I'm just gonna give my
quick my quick two cents on this
um yeah I think one big interesting
undercurring of this season obviously we
know that the Empire is evil it's
efficient in some ways but Andor showed
how it's not efficient in others and
it's dismissive it's destined to fall
apart uh this season the Mandalorian is
showing us how the new Republic is
destined to fall apart as well just by
being overwhelmed by being poorly
structured by being overly forgiving by
being poorly communicative by having
their priorities out of whack uh by not
having a properly watchful eye on the
resurging threat of of Imperial
loyalists
um now I think we're getting back to
this idea of equating separatism with
democracy which is something that the
Clone Wars show did really well of San
Guerrero was a separatist right right
right the whole episode with sawgrera
and his sister I think is one of my
favorite episodes of Clone Wars uh and
this idea of democracy that you know the
difference between a republic and a
democracy is something that is uh
interesting political debate currently
in America right now uh but the idea of
using the Senate the galactic Senate is
not a direct democracy it's a republic
right so you're representing you're
having people represent you and then
voting on your behalf specifically
plazier 15 is they use the term direct
democracy which means like everything is
decided through public uh State ballots
basically like every little thing people
just vote on every question and then so
the political leaders are really just
like Prime Ministers but even then like
everything is just decided through a
direct democracy and yeah there's like
political theorists who can argue that
that is not the ideal form of government
because like you you need like it's like
living in California are if you look at
our ballots like you guys both know this
you live in California we vote on
everything we vote on should there be
dog catchers on Tuesdays through
thurso defund the dog catchers let the
dogs roam free I say I love dogs I say
net those Shih Tzus and throw them in
the back of them
how dare you hard no on the dog catcher
ballot but yeah I think that's like now
they're making an argument that like a
direct democracy might have something to
go for we I don't know if it's fair to
call uh commissioner Hellgate evil per
se I wanted to give you more time to
talk I wanted to hear hear him out and
say why is Count Dooku right like
um like what are the merits of support
democracy he did seem actually very like
remorseful that he let the duchess down
like he did have like a loyalty to this
character who was we learned like you're
saying Eric an elected leader but still
royalty but an elected leader and I
think going back to what you're asking
is why is Star Wars now interested in
this character out Dooku and I think the
answer is a couple of things first of
all Christopher Lee is awesome and I
think everyone can agree that we didn't
get enough Christopher Lee in the Star
Wars prequel movies right and to to for
George Lucas to give us the idea that a
character was formerly Jedi and then
goes over to the dark side before Anakin
Skywalker does you know that's such a
compelling idea and I think that Dave
filoni and team that we're working on
the clone wars were absolutely right to
want to dive into that and to actually
explore that and and recently we were
talking about this before we started
rolling Dave filoni further explored
that in Tales of the Jedi an animated
show that I think is way more
significant and important than than I
think a lot of Star Wars fans kind of
took notice of but that has a few
episodes that actually shows how Dooku
being a a Jedi who believes in Justice
and equality and fairness could look at
what the Republic was then and decide oh
they're corrupt this this isn't gonna
work and how he slowly turns to the dark
side and I think that it's it's it's
absolute absolutely interesting to look
at every era of Star Wars even as far
back as what is supposed to be the
utopian time of the high Republic and
I'm reading some of those books and
comic books and stuff right now and even
in those stories they talk about the
failings of certain aspects of their
Galactic government
because all of that stuff needs to be in
the background if this is a world if
this is a Galaxy where evil can rise up
and and be a a an authoritative force
and an oppressive force and to go back
to the Mandalorian for a second I know
that fans have been upset that the
sequel Trilogy introduced the idea that
the first order could rise after the
empire was defeated after the heroes of
the Rebellion actually defeated the big
bad
um because we wanted a happy ending for
everybody but I think that the
Mandalorian is very smartly showing the
new Republic in this light of if it's an
ineffective government and I know Eric I
think you've talked about this before
too those are the conditions for where a
new uh fascistic government is going to
be able to gain power and gain favor
from people and to be able to convince
people to go and join up as
Stormtroopers or go and you know give
them money or go and support or whatever
the case may be but you have to have
these political undertones in Star Wars
it was always there from the beginning
and I think that what the mandalorians
doing pointing to the sequel Trilogy
saying that the first order Rises
because the new Republic is ineffective
is actually further strengthening the
power of the original trilogy's Empire
the empire was so destructive that it
destroyed a hundreds of years old like
peaceful Galaxy Republic in a government
and was only around for about 30 years
right we saw the beginning of the Empire
to the end of the empire in 20 some
years and it had such a devastating
effect that even after they're defeated
the new Republic's like trying to pick
up the pieces and Tim Meadows is like
look we don't have the resources we
don't you know and and that leads to of
course the first order is going to rise
up again so there was a World War II
after World War one and a lot of the
same players were involved that's how
this stuff goes so I think it's very
very interesting to have Star Wars
actually refocus and and and look at
what the separatists you know uh
political ideology actually was now did
they use droids for nefarious purposes
and maybe uh team up with the wrong
people Palpatine behind the scenes yes
that's the whole point he was trying to
stoke that fire so that he could go oh
the separatists are so bad we have to
put me in charge
George was a genius is what I'm saying I
agree I also explored on a little show
called the bad batch this season guys
episodes one and two take place on
Dooku's home planet uh they deal with
some of the surviving separatists on
that planet that he ultimately turned on
as well uh in the end greed conquers all
and Dooku just started resource hoarding
uh and and taking everyone's money and
and sweet sweet spice and jewels yeah I
think that's what I'm I'm missing in
this uh I I really love the the time
they gave to the separatist cause with
sagerera but really it was like a
militaristic approach I want a boring
PBS C-SPAN Civic debate yes the merits
of separatism democracy in the Star Wars
Universe I will read a term paper on
this I I mean I think that's what kind
of like threw me and maybe it's just
because I was you know briefly uh a
nerdy academic political science major
in college and I did spend too many
times reading too much time reading
these books and thinking about it and
like getting the Facebook debates with
people on this stuff but like
realistically if you were to see a
direct democracy in the Star Wars
Universe it's hard to reconcile that
with the luxuriousness of pleasure 15.
I'm wondering like how are they getting
their money is it like olds Royal wealth
and that's kind of like with Count Dooku
as well is he was such like a flair for
fashion and real in the real world
direct democracy is a very boring thing
like I would imagine a planet that is a
true experiment direct democracy would
be pretty like uh like it'd be very
egalitarian uh everyone would just be
wearing probably Civic uniforms it'd be
something like District 13 and Hunger
Games you know yeah like it would just
it I don't think it would be like hey
we're playing you know Disney's Alice in
Wonderland croquet right now right uh
hanging out with using the force I don't
think the public would would vote to
allow to have the former Royals they
would probably abolish the monarchy
right right exactly yeah I want to read
a newspaper from plazier 15. I really
like I would I think that would be some
fans should make a like Daily Newspaper
just one edition of uh the comings and
goings of that planet now guys I gotta
ask this is the question on my mind now
that the mandalorians have Gideon's
light Cruiser what the fet is next I I
wish that we had had some time because
obviously this is a boca ton season
right it's clear at this point she is
the main hero of the season I don't have
a problem with that it's just like we
didn't see ax woes turn on her that all
happened off screen they're just like
talking about it and we didn't even like
she mentioned it with like a throwaway
line in episode one and she seemed kind
of bitter but oh she doesn't seemed kind
of comfortable sitting in a throne she
just seemed kind of bored yeah than
anything she didn't look bitter in
defeat yeah like the lowest moment for
Boca Town in the season is when her
castle and kalavala got bombed right she
was wearing a helmet and we immediately
cut away from her for a doctor-pershing
storyline for 40 minutes right and by
the time we cut back with her she
immediately got a new home on the covert
Planet it's like we haven't really seen
Boca time struggle or have like any kind
of personal gripe with these people
other than this moment right now so it
was like a payoff to something that we
didn't see so like we didn't really know
what it means for her to regain this I
would say like clone wars and Rebels
challenge the character at Boca tan and
and more dramatic and more interesting
ways than this live-action show has it's
nothing against Katie Sackhoff I think
she's great I just think like
structurally this season is just kind of
scattered all over the place and it's
not really given us a chance to like
connect with her emotionally uh and and
then I also just gotta say I love
watching two mandalorians fight with
each other but is the flamethrower
necessary no I know it looks really cool
I don't mind it but how is that
practically useful when they're fighting
each other like I'm mad now
stay away
especially because that little Shield
looked like it was only maybe trash can
lit size but it still took the whole
brunt of the fire and I'm like I'm gonna
need that weapon explained because that
doesn't make any physical sense it makes
about as much sense and obeying the laws
of physics is Captain America's
vibranium Shield but it is very very
cool and I think that to your point Eric
I think that Boca tan has been a a huge
Focus this season I think that the
relationship between her and denjarin is
something that they've been spending
episodes sort of building up so that
when you get to this moment where
she goes to bat for him and then he
explains like she's the rightful owner
of the darksaber the YouTube comments
were right they over thought this and
they were correct like she's the one who
should get this through the rule of you
know losing it in battle and defeating
whoever had it in battle I think that
that is a payoff that it would have been
more difficult to achieve considering
where the characters how they felt about
each other at the beginning of this
season you had to have those bonding
episodes you have to have the episodes
where they both saved the kid of the
Mandalorian covert you know against a
big pterodactyl creature the Raptor the
Raptor you're right the bird of prey but
to have her defend dingarn and go like
he's cool he's he's he's good guys he's
a cool dude and he may have different
religious beliefs than us but he is
Mandalorian just the same as we are I
think it's all leading towards the end
of the season feels like it's going to
be who is going to be the one that's
really going to unite the Mandalorian
claims is it going to be bo or is it
going to be denjarin and it looks like
it's leaning towards Bo but if it is
where does that leave DIN and grow are
they going to stay with this group and
this found family or are they going to
find their own path and continue the
sort of wandering Samurai tradition that
the Mandalorian is inspired by so yeah
we will find out I honestly think when
they when they brought grogu and Mando
back together in the book of Boba Fett a
different show I think they kind of ran
out of ideas of what to do with those
two characters so they're like let's
just do a boca tan season it just seems
like that's what fellonium Favre did
they're like we like bogoton we like
Katie Sackhoff let's just do a season
where she's a hero because like what
have we learned about din jarin or grogu
this season grogu started babbling and
he can now do these big jumps yeah and I
think like there's been little moments
like din
encouraging grogu to like
train with the other Mandalorian kids
sure sure with them but even that has
felt kind of like out not necessarily
out of place but like it sticks out
because it's like oh this is a rare din
is paying attention to grogu and like
teaching him something moment now we're
gonna get back to this other storyline
where Raptors are plucking children out
of the sky on the most day on the most
dangerous beach in the world do you guys
think it's because the characters of
dinjarin and grogu are such sort of
stoic and simple I want to say shallow
characters like when we met din at the
beginning of season one what was his
ultimate sort of story arc is that he he
he's he's a mercenary but you we knew by
the end of episode one and you saw that
little hand come up that he was probably
going to fall in love with this kid and
become an adoptive father and what else
have we learned about din he was
prejudiced against droids but now he's
cool with them depending on like right
that's that's those are basically the
two things that have changed within din
jarin who's a very you know man with no
name Sergio Leone like like Clint
Eastwood stoic character that doesn't
have too much complexity in him and
grogu's also a puppet who doesn't
talk it's very difficult to put
in yeah personality and wants and needs
and desires other than like grogu
looking at things and squinting and you
know and other characters sort of
projecting their own like you shall be a
Mandalorian you shall be Jedi so these
two characters are are action figures
and I don't mean that in a bad way I
mean it in a good way it's totally fine
but do you guys think that that this
season in particular it has really kind
of become more glaring because Eric you
mentioned like well the resolution of of
him and and grogu happened we saw that
in the book of Boba Fett where else can
these characters go per se or do you
think that it's still something where
the show's writing can still rise to the
challenge I think they can still rise to
the challenge I think that the one of
the problems with not problems but one
of the struggles the show faces is that
grogu ages so slowly so we can't because
if grow Goku was really going full on
like becoming a Mandalorian that would
be really cool but that's going to take
like 15 years okay yeah which will be 15
years will be like he'll then be like a
five-year-old I don't you know like no
he he won't because we saw I don't know
how many years was Order 66 prior to
this like 30 some years something like
that and he looks the same and he was
he's 50 now and he was 20 years old then
so it but even if we get to like the
sequel Trilogy era he's gonna look the
same even if we get past episode 9 rise
of Skywalker and grog will become some
sort of protagonist of episodes 10 11
and 12 or some future Star Wars
storytelling he's gonna look the same
he's a baby oh I don't know about that
babbling my parents have vote that kind
of photo spread of me
from kindergarten through uh through I
believe my senior year of high school
and like I look the same I look the same
I look the same like people look at me
like Eric is this just the same thing
13 here and then suddenly between 18 and
19 I turned into a man yeah man I got a
big Adam's Apple that falls down I got a
couple okay okay I shot up a couple of
feet so we don't know what Yoda species
puberty is like and when it hits us
we were with Baby Groot for a few years
and then he was Teen Groot and he's you
know so you're right you're right we
could absolutely shift around how that
aging works but um but yeah to your
point Tommy it's it's it's difficult to
to treat that character as like a a main
character of the show when I feel like
really he is this great you know he's
like Yoda like Yoda I don't know if Yoda
ever works as a main focused character
in a Star Wars any kind of a long form
thing Yoda focused episodes of The Clone
Wars are fantastic but Yoda is a
character I think sir works best as a
supporting character and I think that's
what grogu is too so yeah yeah I mean I
think the the writing game can rise to
the challenge but you have to be willing
to Kill Your Darlings and I what I I
think a lot of us were theorizing going
into the season especially at the
beginning that they were going to take a
real critical eye at the children of the
watch in the way in the cult Orthodoxy
of it and they have it they've just kind
of like championed it or haven't really
made any kind of bold statement on it
that's what filoni did so well in Clone
in Clone Wars we didn't really sure
where they're gonna go and then season
five comes along and then for the first
time we're questioning the Jedi Order
and we're showing the flaws in their
thinking and to me that's when Clone
Wars is at its best like what's more
beloved than the Jedi in the Star Wars
fandom and they were able to like take
characters like you know Yoda like Mace
Windu like kiari Mundi and then say like
no those guys were clearly wrong-minded
on so many things and restricted and why
don't they do that with this clear cult
like instead they're just like they're
they're having this championing music
when when uh when the armorer is like
take off your helmet she walks in both
worlds it's like
I I look I don't mind a good story of
the week Clone Wars episode Vibe I
there's a lot of people watching this
episode are like I didn't watch Clone
Wars I don't get it I watch new rock
stars videos to explain to me watch
Clone Wars watch it watch it just watch
it but if you watch it I think you're
gonna find some episodes like a jar jar
episode
3PO and R2 are doing what like you know
there are those arcs uh but overall
there's a lot of great arcs in there I
think it is worth watching but yeah I
think this late in the season to have
another one that just kind of feels a
bit scattered structurally it's just
gonna throw some people and I think the
issue is is that people are willing to
nostalgically look back at clone wars
and forgive it because they were younger
when they watched it and those are a lot
of the same people who are now watching
the Mandalorian Clone Wars was 13 years
ago when those first Seasons came out
those people are older now we have seen
more complex sophisticated versions to
tell these stories we've watched Andor
we've watched Rogue one and we've
watched other non-star Wars media that
we've really grown to love you can't
just do the same kind of basic first
draft storytelling with these things and
not like give your characters more
character development and hope that
everyone's just going to be on the same
train we're more like know your audience
and I don't think there's little kids
who are watching this the same with the
same wedge of extent it's like a
live-action show it's not animated you
have to raise the bar a bit with how
much you challenge your characters and
challenge their their assumptions I
agree I think I agree I think that's
exactly it they gotta aim a little
higher I think I just want like if
you're gonna say Dooku is right I want
to know why yeah like to explain why
bring in a just do a bit of Googling
into Political Theory and like give give
a Doc Brown a bit more explanation as to
why right not just that the Jedi were
evil or that you know Palpatine exposed
all of them for their for their flaws
but like get back to some like talk
about the merits of democracy show us in
the episode how like because all we saw
was plazier 15 looks like a failed
experiment if these you can't say that
like direct democracy is great and then
also show like a bunch of like wealthy
one percenters who are doing hat
shopping and needing to do all their
heavy things or Droids that are like
seemingly like a marginalized group uh
uh vulnerable class in this world and
they're you know they're just trying to
like you know just kind of scrape by and
not really get noticed or anything and
and yeah and I wonder if that's like the
struggle that lucasfilm and Star Wars
has right now where maybe these
conversations are being had and they're
going but we already kind of covered
this in the other stuff in the Clone
Wars animated show and the tales of the
Jedi had some Dooku specific Centric
things and maybe because Star Wars does
try to the best of its ability treat all
of their media as like the same level of
importance right like they Star Wars in
the past couple years especially has
reinforced going no no no
characters introduced in animated shows
like Ahsoka and thrawn they're just as
important as characters like Luke
Skywalker and Han Solo and and Rey
Skywalker and and that's very admirable
and I really like that Star Wars tries
to treat all of its media like that I
like that they have gone and said all of
the things we're doing across the board
whether it's in publishing or video
games or VR or whatever we're all trying
to make it as Canon as we can and try to
be respectful to that and not be
redundant but it goes to the
conversation I know that speaking of
tales of the Jedi there was an episode
that was Ahsoka specific towards the end
where where she was fighting one of the
inquisitors right and some fans who have
been consuming all of the Star Wars
media they pointed to a novel that came
out and they said that's an Ahsoka novel
and filoni was sort of like yeah true
because the novel was based on the
novels like an expanded version of what
it what was a treatment that we had
while we were making clone wars and we
never got around to animating it well
now we did tales of the Jedi I just
animated it and it's essentially the
same story and Star Wars fans are going
is Star Wars now being redundant
telling the same story in different
medium when they should have been saying
the book happened it's Canon just go
read this book here's a different Ahsoka
story or is it still important to show
in an animated format a story that maybe
people who are not readers would have
never experienced would it be redundant
if Eric like you're saying if they had
Christopher Lloyd give us a little more
about Dooku and his in his ideology when
Star Wars fans would go yeah we've seen
this already we watch this this and this
but should they should should Star Wars
be trying to treat every one of their
projects like it's someone's first and
only Star Wars are there people who
really truly are only watching the
Mandalorian and didn't watch the book of
Boba Fett in between Seasons two and
three that's kind of wild to me but I
understand I'm not a normal person I
like to consume Star Wars at every
single Iota and atom and that's not most
General audiences approach to this kind
of thing so is Star Wars trying to
respect their own stuff that they've
already done or should they be thinking
about this as every single one of these
projects should be entry level and the
only thing a Star Wars fan ever sees
that's a really interesting point Hector
I think you're asking the right
questions because yeah obviously I
assume internally that's what they're
asking themselves to I think when
they're at their best they're doing both
they're they're telling a story that
anybody who hasn't seen a single episode
of Clone Wars and Rebels can watch tune
in and enjoy
um and then uh but they throw in little
Easter eggs or little you know Zeb
cameos whatever it is that people can go
online and then get explanations on what
it is but what what made the Zed Cameo
last week so brilliant is that like you
didn't need to know who Zeb was to
appreciate that moment you're just like
here's a really well CGI character uh
just who has this connection with with
the
and it's like just saying you need to
yeah good luck trying to get something
out of the new Republic in a cool Top
Gun setting like that's all we needed
um but yeah this episode it's just like
I think if anybody were to tune in
without knowing clone wars and Clone
Wars I think they're really gonna be
thrown by this episode I guess we have
to ask Leonardo DiCaprio who you know
who we know watches the Mandalorian I
don't know if Leonardo DiCaprio has
watched Clone Wars I don't think he has
but maybe he has because he can better
relate to his girlfriend's ages yeah do
you think Leo DiCaprio's uh when he sees
that that uh the actress who played the
quarin was 24 years older than the guy
who played the mon calamari and he's
gonna be like no that doesn't make it
he's got it reverse now it's unrealistic
he says yeah yeah I think he went yeah
all right let's get out of here we've
embarrassed we'll leave it there for
this episode of Wookie link safe you
don't know what we're talking about with
DiCaprio hey just never Google Your
Heroes I guess
um but we'll leave it there and uh hey I
know we've been hard on this episode but
we're that's what these reaction shows
are to do you know we still overall we
love these characters we love that this
show exists at all we're happy to have
like live action Star Wars to talk about
every week so yeah no Faults there but
um the Easter egg breakdown again will
come out tomorrow you can follow me at
eavas you follow Tommy Tommy backward
you can follow Hector and Hector is
funny and uh we will be back next week
to react to season three episode seven
uh which will be directed by Rick family
these final two episodes will be so I'm
very excited to see what they're gonna
do they're on
you can uh check out the uh the Deep
dive on Friday uh we'll be doing a deep
dive into Christopher Nolan's
Interstellar uh I think it's gonna be a
really great one hopefully you watch it
enjoy it you can follow new Rockstar
subscribe to WikiLeaks wherever you get
your podcast thank you watch it and
we'll bring back our original sign off
yeah it's returning we we have spoken
foreign